claudia jumper gerade nicht tun doch der
ganze glanz hilft nicht weiter denn ihre
tanzstunde mitten in münchen ist
beschlossen
150 kinder fehlen und damit auch jede
menge mitgliedsbeiträge die die miete
und ihre fünf tanzlehrer finanzieren die
lehrer bricht die ganze existenz
zusammen genauso wie für die tanzstudios
manche eltern sie noch bereit zu
bezahlen die beiträge aber natürlich
will man sehen auf dauer wird mit diesen
status nicht halten können und entstehen
wir wirklich vor dem aus heute morgen
vor dem münchner arbeitsamt endlos
schlangen all jene die nun um ihre
existenz kämpfen und auf staatliche
hilfen dringend warten
ganz konkret können betriebe in bayern
ab morgen einen antrag auf finanzielle
soforthilfe stellen gestaffelt nach
anzahl der beschäftigen bei bis zu fünf
beschäftigten maximal 5000 euro bei bis
zu zehn beschäftigten 7500 euro bis zu
50 beschäftigte 15.000 euro bis zu 250
beschäftigte 30.000 euro diese woche
noch soll das erste geld an die
kleineren und mittleren betriebe die
tatsächliche liquiditätsprobleme haben
überwiesen werden
es handelt sich dabei um zuschüsse nicht
um kredite auch der bund unterstützt mit
einem milliardenschweren hilfsprogramm
kurzarbeitergeld liquiditätshilfen in
form von günstigen krediten
diese richten sich auch an größere
konzerne wie etwa lufthansa und opel die
mit den hilfen später schulden leichter
zurückzahlen
bund und land im schulterschluss so
gesehen hatte die pressekonferenz von
bundesgesundheitsminister sparen und
ministerpräsident söder heute in gestik
und ton regelrechte symbolkraft whatever
it takes was auch immer nötig ist doch
selbst das ist an diesem tag nicht
wundern
wir bitten den bund sowohl die
lohnfortzahlung im krankheitsfall als
auch das kurzarbeitergeld als auch das
arbeitslosengeld anzupassen auf die
cologne herausforderung denn es wird
unternehmen geben die zu machen es wird
unternehmen geben die sich zurückhalten
werden oder ganz wundervoll markus
eisele will das auf gar keinen fall
der kinobetreiber aus fürstenfeldbruck
hat die meisten seiner 75 mitarbeiter
bereits in kurzarbeit geschickt sein
ziel hat er klar vor augen
natürlich ist unser plan dann irgendwann
auch wieder aufmachen zu können und wir
können ja dann nicht von null starten
sondern wir müssen sie mit den
vorhandenen team starten und so geben
mich dann er begriffe wie
liquiditätshilfen kurzarbeitergeld
soforthilfen den menschen in diesen
tagen vor allem auch eines zuversicht
und hoffnung und live zugeschaltet ist
mir jetzt bundeswirtschaftsminister
peter altmaier guten abend herr altmaier
guten abend zimmermann zuschüsse aus
bayern das land hilft seinen film also
mit geldgeschenken und nicht nur mit
krediten
irgendwann wieder zurückgezahlt werden
müssen warum gibt es das nicht
bundesweit
doch es gibt es natürlich bundesweit wir
haben das kurzarbeitergeld reformiert
das gesetz in rekordzeit verabschiedet
und man kann anträge stellen rückwirkend
zum ersten märz das ist für ganz ganz
viele arbeitnehmer entscheidend denn
damit verlieren sie ihren arbeitsplatz
nicht und sie sind wieder verfügbar wenn
das wachstum wieder fahrt aufnimmt
sobald diese krise überwunden des
zweitens wir machen steuerstundungen
verzichten auf vollstreckungsmaßnahmen
damit die unternehmen nicht zusätzlich
in schwierigkeiten kommen drittens es
gibt kredite und garantien in der tat zu
betriebsmitteln und wir sind uns einig
der finanzminister und der
wirtschaftsminister also ich in dem fall
dass wir alles tun wollen was darüber
hinaus möglich ist im augenblick schauen
wir uns an wie das aussieht mit
mietkosten die etwa entstehen bei
gaststätten und bei geschäftslokalen
wir schauen uns an welche probleme wir
lösen müssen ganz kurzfristig wenn es
darum geht dass eltern zu hause bleiben
müssen um ihre kinder zu betreuen weil
sie keinen ersatz haben und dann nicht
zur arbeit gehen können
wir sind entschlossen diese fragen der
reihe nach anzupacken und zu lösen
trotzdem raus zuschüsse in bayern sind
nicht geplant
reichen denn die kreditprogramme aus auf
die sie ja vor allem setzen und wie
schnell helfen sie jetzt ich glaube sie
haben mich nicht ganz richtig verstanden
ich habe gesagt wir werden alles tun was
notwendig ist
und natürlich wollen wir den unternehmen
helfen die durch die korona krise in
schwierigkeiten geraten sind
und ich schließe überhaupt gar nicht aus
im gegenteil ich halte es für richtig
dass wir einen härtefallfonds etablieren
aber da es sich um das geld der
bürgerinnen und bürger handelt was wir
ausgeben müssen wir natürlich dann auch
die kriterien festlegen was die
voraussetzung dafür ist und es muss
schnell an den mann und an die frau
gebracht werden
gehen wir mal von so einem härtefall aus
was es wenn unternehmen gerade kleine
kredite nicht zurückzahlen kann dann
gibt es ja die möglichkeit dass man auch
mit den banken vereinbart dass gestundet
wird das auch für hohe zinsen verzichtet
wird die zinsen sind ja gott sei dank in
dieser phase sehr niedrig und wir werden
auch von bundesebene aus alles tun damit
in den nächsten wochen und monaten kein
schädlicher druck entsteht wir haben zum
beispiel von anfang an gesagt wir werden
vollstreckungsmaßnahmen im steuerbereich
bis zum ende des jahres aussetzen weil
wir genügend zeit haben wollen um den
unternehmen ihre aufgabe zu erleichtern
vielen dank herr altmaier für das
gespräch panikartige ausverkauf an den
börsen weltweit dax und dow jones im
keller da lassen auch historische
vergleiche zur finanzkrise 2008 nicht
lange auf sich warten
vieles ist gerade unkalkulierbar für die
wirtschaft dabei ist laut experten aber
nicht mehr die frage ob es eine
rezession geben wird sondern vielmehr
wie dramatisch sie ausfällt claus kleber
berichtet alles muss raus sogar die
osterhasen und das schon drei wochen vor
dem fest der einzelhandel in frankfurt
versucht noch
so viel ware wie möglich an die wenigen
kunden zu bringen die unterwegs sind
ab morgen sind auch hier die meisten
läden und geschäfte dicht in den
fußgängerzonen deutschlands wird es
sichtbar
die rezession ist nicht mehr zu stoppen
so etwas hat es auch in der konjunktur
aufzeichnung noch nicht gegeben eine
solche blitz rezession wo binnen tagen
die perspektiven für die wirtschaft sich
um 180 grad gedreht haben und das
weltweit das spürt man auch hier auf dem
börsenparkett wo die kurse seit wochen
nur eine richtung kennen
mit einem minus von 33 prozent seit
anfang des jahres steuert der dax auf
das schwärzeste quartal seiner
geschichte zu dabei ziehen notenbank und
politik alle register zinssenkungen
notkredite konjunkturprogramme alles
scheint zu verpuffen
die märkte sind deshalb so panisch weil
die unterstützungsmaßnahmen derzeit
überhaupt noch nicht greifen können denn
es geht ja aktuell darum die korona bios
an sich zu besiegen und wenn die
menschen zu hause sind können sie nicht
konsumieren deshalb helfen eben diese
ganzen unterstützungsprogramme aktuell
noch nicht und jeden tag kommen neue
hiobsbotschaften aus der wirtschaft
immer mehr luftfahrtunternehmen
beantragen staatshilfe zuletzt boeing
und die lufthansa airbus hält seine
produktion an
auch bei deutschlands großen autobauern
vw und daimler stehen die bänder bald
still
das trifft vor allem die zulieferer mit
hunderttausenden arbeitsplätzen und
möglicherweise die banken wenn kredite
in größerem stil ausfallen sollten
hauptaufgabe der notenbanken besteht
darin dass der virus nicht auch noch vom
unternehmenssektor in den bankensektor
überspringt das heißt also das system
stabil zu halten und hier haben wir
derzeit ich auch sehr gute ergebnisse
heißt ein run auf die banken wohl
zunächst nicht zu befürchten
sie erscheinen heute viel
widerstandsfähiger als noch bei der
lehman pleite
am besten wäre allerdings man müsste
dies gar nicht erst austesten und ein
impfstoff gegen das virus wurde so
schnell wie möglich
wie sicher ist mein geld das umtreibt
jetzt auch viele sparer und
privatanleger live zugeschaltet ist mir
dazu der wirtschaftsjournalist hermann
josef tenhagen in hamburg guten abend
herr ten hagen einen guten abend
unterlagen
wer jetzt geld in aktien investiert hat
was sollte der jetzt tun
er sollte das aussitzen wenn es irgend
kann also wenn er längere zeit das geld
nicht braucht dann lässt er das geld in
aktien stehen hat es vielleicht in fonds
an indexfonds stehen dann kann er das
auch aussitzen in der vergangenheit war
das so dass man selbst wenn der die
internationalen aktien um 50 prozent
runter waren mal nach einigen jahren
wieder in der gewinnzone war das kann
man aushalten probleme haben nur die
menschen die in diesem jahr dieses geld
aus ihren aktien brauchen auch die
banken werden ja von der kommune krise
hart getroffen wie sicher ist dass dann
das ersparte wenn es jetzt auf dem
girokonto zum beispiel liegt also wir
haben ja in europa diese regelung dass
100.000 euro auf jedem konto pro person
sicher sind das heißt man kann 100.000
euro auf dem tagesgeld oder auf dem
festgeldkonto bei seiner bank haben das
sollte man auch haben und in deutschland
haben wir eigentlich regelungen die
darüber hinausgehen aber wenn man seine
100.000 euro abgesichert hat dann ist
man der da auf der sicheren seite und
ganz generell gehe ich dann jetzt am
besten mit meinem geld zum ausgeben geht
ja gerade party nicht nein also ganz
generell ist es tatsächlich so dass ich
ganz klassische strategie fahre ich habe
geld auf dem tagesgeldkonto damit ich
nicht in den dispo brauche das hilft mir
auch in so einer phase wenn ich jetzt
arbeitslos werde oder wenn ich
kurzarbeitergeld bekommen damit ich über
die runden komme dann habe ich
vielleicht wenn ich mehr geld übrig
haben noch ein bisschen was auf dem
festgeldkonto für das nächste auto was
ich kaufen will und über die lange frist
wenn man denn keine immobilie hat und
nicht die hacke von schulden wegen der
immobilie dann sind aktien oder aktien
indexfonds tatsächlich das richtige wir
haben das bei finanztipps durchprobiert
immer wieder über 10 15 jahre über 15
jahre in der vergangenheit im schnitt 7
bis 8 prozent und wie gesagt über 15
jahre selbst bei den schweren krisen der
letzten drei jahrzehnte nie ein verlust
was bedeuten da dann wo eine rezession
für alterssicherung
zum beispiel für die pensionskassen und
betriebsrenten ja für die ist natürlich
sozusagen das ergebnis vor allen dingen
dass die wirtschaft nicht weiter wächst
und dass da an der stelle sozusagen die
zusätzlichen zahlungen weniger werden
genau wie bei der gesetzlichen rente
wenn man muss bei allen altersvorsorge
liegen davon ausgehen nicht das
irgendwie das gefährdet ist sondern das
ist einfach deutlich weniger wird im
nächsten jahr und im übernächsten jahr
durch diese krise als als geplant war
das heißt man hat dann vielleicht
hinterher drei oder vier oder fünf
prozent weniger rente als man sonst
gehabt hätte das ist sehr bitter für
viele leute aber es ist nicht so etwas
was ein umbringt vielen dank hermann
josef tenhagen für diese einschätzung um
mögliche schließungen der eu
außengrenzen und auch die auswirkungen
auf die wirtschaft ging es heute in
einem video gipfel der eu staaten und
regierung eu staats und regierungschefs
bundeskanzlerin merkel will in kürze in
berlin vor die presse treten
fragen wir nach bei theo koll in berlin
die kanzlerin zeigt sich immer präsenter
in der krise hat ihre strategie geändert
ganz offensichtlich wir erleben momentan
in gewisser weise eine art wieder
dynamisiert kanzlerin wochen ja monate
lang wurden die rufe immer lauter wo ist
die kanzlerin was macht sie eigentlich
beruflich also sie schien lange
abgetaucht es hat das virus jetzt
verändert es ist schon die dritte
presseunterrichtungen durch die
kanzlerin innerhalb von wenigen tagen
anfangs hatte sie ja vieles in dieser
krise ihren gesundheitsminister
überlassen und jetzt ist völlig klar die
regierungschefin übernimmt das ruder und
das natürlich auf ihre sehr nüchterne
und er gelassener hatte so pathetische
formulierungen haben wir von ihr bisher
nicht gehört wie gestern vom
französischen präsidenten der er sagte
man sei im krieg gegen das virus das ist
natürlich nicht die sache von angela
merkel aber sie lässt er noch keinen
zweifel an der größe dieser krise was
sind die dringendsten probleme für die
kanzlerin auf europäischer ebene nun auf
europäischer ebene geht es vor allem um
die aufrechterhaltung des
wirtschaftsverkehrs an den europäischen
binnengrenzen und natürlich auch um die
pendler mobilität der wichtige
streitpunkt dabei ist die grenzfrage
denn wir erleben das immer
mehr regierungen einseitig
grenzkontrollen eingeführt haben oder
sogar grenzen ganz geschlossen haben
frau von der leyen hatte versucht es zu
verhindern sie hatte vorgeschlagen ein
reisen in die eu für nicht eu bürger für
30 tage zu stoppen
das im prinzip mit dem ziel dadurch die
kontrollen innerhalb der eu zu lockern
also das ist sicherlich der schwierigere
teil heute der verhandlung
denn im moment sieht sich jedes land auf
sich selbst zurück und machte im prinzip
die grenzen dicht frankreich war ja
schon vor dieser heutigen video
konferenz vorgeprescht und hatte die
einreisebeschränkungen einseitig in
kraft gesetzte zusätzlich zu der
drakonischen ausgangssperre die immer
neu marx gestern verhängt hat also das
ist das zentrale dieses heutigen video
gipfels muss man ja sagen dass man
versucht die binnengrenzen zu lockern
zwischen den einzelnen staaten weil im
moment jedes land versucht mit dieser
krise selbst fertig zu werden und die
europäische offenheit darunter leidet
vielen dank für diese einschätzung
und das war es von diesem zdf spezial
weitere informationen zu corona krise
sehen sie hier gleich nach den rosenheim
cops in einem weiteren zdf spezial um 20
uhr 30
dann unter anderem mit fragen an den
wissenschaftler und philosophen harald
lesch und auch in maybrit illner spezial
wird es heute um die korona pandemie
gehen ich wünsche ihnen noch einen
schönen abend
[Musik]
maybrit illner spezial mit dem thema
corona krise kampf gegen die pandemie
unter anderem mit kanzleramtsminister
helge braun jörg radek gewerkschaft der
polizei und frank ulrich montgomery chef
des welt erste bundes maybrit illner
spezial 22 15 im zdf